[موسيقى]
لم تتوقف في الخلافات بشان الاتفاق
الايطالي الموقع في الخامس من ديسمبر
الماضي والذي ينص على اخراج الجيش من
الحياه السياسيه في السودان وتشكيل حكومه
مدنيه تقود البلاد خلال فتره انتقاليه في
الفتره الاخيره خفت خلافات المدنيين قليلا
وطفت الى السطح خلافات العسكريين وتمركزت
حول نقطتين هما ادماج قوات الدعم السريع
التي يقودها محمد حمدان حميتي في الجيش
وتوسيع دائره المشاركه المدنيه قال عبد
الفتاح البرهان رئيس مجلس السياده
الانتقالي ان دعم الجيش للاتفاق الايطالي
السياسي مرهون بتنفيذ بند دمج قوات الدعم
السريع في الجيش فيما قال محمد حمدان
حميتي نائب رئيس مجلس سياده السوداني انه
ملتزم بدمج قوات الدعم السريع في الجيش
وفق جداول زمنيه متفق عليها مع اعتبر دعوه
لاصلاح الجيش قبل الدمج من مطالب البرهان
ايضا توسيع دائره المشاركه السياسيه اذ
قال ان الجيش لن يمضي في الاتفاق مع جهه
واحده موضحا انه لا احد يقبل ان تسوقه فئه
معينه دون مشاركه بقيه الاطراف في المقابل
يقول احمدتي في اشاره الى ما يريدون توسيع
قاعده المشاركه انهم اعدوا ورقه وحددوا
ثمانيه اطراف او تسعه مما يصفونهم الان
بانهم قليل العدد ووقعوا معهم
[موسيقى]